hola en nuestro último vídeo intentamos
aproximar el lara bajo la curva
construyendo cuatro rectángulos con la
misma base para evaluar la función y
determinar su altura respectivamente
pero lo que quiero realizar en este
vídeo es generalizar las cosas un poco
utilizando el mismo método pero
haciéndolo para una función arbitraria
con límites arbitrarios y con un número
arbitrario de rectángulos así que pues
vamos a hacerlo primero déjame realizar
el diagrama para hacer las cosas un poco
más claras lo más claras posibles y
bueno aquí está nuestro eje de las yes y
luego tendríamos por acá nuestro eje de
las x entonces vamos a marcar una
función arbitraria que sería algo así la
cual va a ser igual a efe x y luego
vamos a definir los límites entonces por
aquí digamos que tenemos por aquí
tenemos x
igualada entonces aquí vamos x igualada
y por acá tenemos a x igual a b entonces
diremos después de que ya marcamos estos
límites para nuestra función que tenemos
en el rectángulos n rectángulos y luego
voy a decir que cada uno de mis
rectángulos estará determinado por una
altura dicha altura va a hacer por
ejemplo en este primer caso para nuestro
primer rectángulo la va a marcar a donde
a aquí está retrasándose como fedea
entonces estaba delimitar nuestra altura
de nuestro primer rectángulo que sería
de esta forma entonces lo voy a sombrear
y este es nuestro primer rectángulo y
luce algo así y bueno antes de seguir
quiero hacer como una especie de
convención o etiqueta para cada uno de
nuestros límites que están dividiendo
nuestros rectángulos entonces aquí
digamos que ya va a ser lo mismo que x 0
entonces este límite que no se está
definiendo nuestro nuestra altura de
nuestro rectángulo va a ser igual a x0 y
viene ahora que ya tenemos una especie
de notación vamos con este segundo
rectángulo el cual ahora estará
delimitado por x1 entonces su altura va
a estar definido por efe de x 1 como lo
vemos por aquí entonces nuestro segundo
rectángulo nuestro segundo rectángulo
luce algo así vamos a sombrear lo
y bueno con la misma idea vamos a pasar
a nuestro tercer rectángulo entonces lo
voy a pintar ahora de color azul para
que vayan vaya quedando todo diferente
entonces ahora vemos que es estará
delimitado por efe de x2 y luce de la
siguiente forma
este es nuestro tercer rectángulo y bien
siguiendo la misma idea siguiendo la
misma idea para todos nuestros
rectángulos vamos al enésimo rectángulo
como puedes ver bueno aquí estaré a su
límite izquierdo y para denotar cuál
sería qué punto sería para nuestro
enésimo rectángulo podemos observar que
para cuando tenemos nuestro primer
rectángulo su límite izquierdo era x 0
para ese 1 del rectángulo x 1 y para
nuestro tercer rectángulo sería x 2
entonces siguiendo la misma idea este
punto de aquí que está delimitando
nuestro nuestra altura sería x n menos
ahora cualquiera que sea el rectángulo
su límite izquierdo será ese número
menos 1 y solo está basado como
convención que nosotros hemos definido
para llevar un orden y bueno la
siguiente cosa que vamos a realizar s
calculamos el área
abajo la curva con la suma de cada área
particularmente pero primero antes de
seguir con dicho cálculo me gustaría que
superamos lo siguiente como propósito de
este vídeo o de este ejemplo pues me
gustaría asumir que la base para el
cálculo de cada área es la misma la cual
llamaremos delta x y será de la
siguiente forma será la distancia que
hay de todo nuestro intervalo de dicha
función sobre el número de intervalos
que queremos entre n entonces esa será
delta x nuestra base ahora bien sabemos
que a es igual a x0 por lo que entonces
x1 será igual a x0 más delta x x2 se da
igual a x1 + delta x y siguiendo con la
misma lógica entonces x cn va a ser
igual a x n menos uno más delta
y lo que hemos hecho de esencialmente es
establecer este diagrama que hemos
dibujado anteriormente donde b es igual
a x en ella a su vez es x n menos 1 +
delta x y bueno creo que ahora sí
podríamos pensar que toda esta anotación
o convención que hemos hecho es para
llevar un orden dentro del cálculo de
nuestra área o nuestra aproximación
nuestra aproximación de nuestra área por
lo que entonces el área aproximada a que
será igual
bien pues por aquí viéndolo del área de
nuestro primer rectángulo lo voy a
escribir por aquí abajo y entonces sería
el área de nuestro primer rectángulo más
el área de nuestro segundo rectángulo
más el área de este tercer rectángulo y
así la suma de todas nuestras áreas
hasta el enésimo rectángulo y entonces
esto va a ser la siguiente forma tenemos
que ésta es nuestra altura de nuestro
primer rectángulo para multiplicar que
sería base por altura
efe por la base donde dijimos que dan
las mismas por delta x delta x pero para
llevar una misma notación voy a poner
que es f de x 0 por delta x es en
realidad lo mismo simplemente lo puse lo
desde lo de x 0
entonces de nuestro segundo rectángulo
sería f x 1 por delta x luego para
nuestro tercer rectángulo fx 2 por delta
equis y así sucesivamente hasta llegar a
efe de x n 1 como vemos por aquí que su
límite izquierdo sería f de x n menos 1
por delta x también y listo
aquí tenemos el área bajo nuestra curva
pero para hacerlo más cómodo y también
que es lo más común que puedes encontrar
cuando la gente habla de áreas
aproximadas o sumas en general usan la
famosa sigma por lo que de otro modo
para describir esto sin embargo dice
exactamente lo mismo será de la
siguiente forma sea la suma representada
por nuestro símbolo sigma que va a ir
desde igual a uno hasta n lo cual está
representando nuestros nuestro número de
rectángulos que van desde 1 hasta n
nuestra función evaluada en cada uno de
estos x sub índice que van a ir desde i
igual a uno hasta n y como vemos sería
de x menos 1 por delta x y esto es en
general una forma de representar nos el
área bajo la curva aproximada es el área
bajo la curva en la cual nosotros
utilizamos el límite izquierdo por lo
cual nos queda el subíndice y menos uno
entonces lo que nos dice este subíndice
es que lo que podemos hacer es tener
cuidado para cuando tomemos un límite
izquierdo o un límite derecho y bien eso
es lo que determina nuestra altura y
también lo multiplicamos por nuestra
base que para todo caso es delta equis y
pues bien ésta es la suma de todos los
rectángulos donde van desde el primero
hasta el enésimo y nos da la
aproximación finalmente espero que haya
sido mucho más como ese tipo de notación
pues no hicimos nada diferente a nuestro
vídeo anterior simplemente genera
nuestra notación con algo más matemático